chaussin chabot est agriculteur de père
en fils
al'annonce du confinement général et de
la fermeture des frontières de la france
il a craint le pire pour sa récolte des
asperges qui commençait tout juste à
pointer la tête hors du sol sableux nu
les employés les cueilleurs son origine
d'origine espagnole donc ils viennent
d'andalousie tous les ans donc premier
problème la cueillette
comment accueillir les j'espère cette
année d'habitude j'ai pas du tout le
monde française pour la france entière
ce sont environ 200 mille travailleurs
saisonniers qui viennent normalement du
maroc de la tunisie ou encore de
l'espagne qui se retrouve exclue de
l'hexagone et les récoltes comme celle
de monsieur chabot ne peuvent pas
attendre
ils sont français jeunes et en santé ils
ont répondu à l'appel du ministère de
l'agriculture en prêtant leurs bras ou
ultimate heures de france court de main
d'oeuvre pour que la france puisse
manger ils ont comme guillaume un
chômeur rejoint les rangs de ce que le
gouvernement appelle la grande armée de
l'agriculture française on est en train
de faire un petit champ donc ça nourrit
une petite partie de la population dont
on imagine la grande grande échelle un
petit peu ce que ça doit impliquer pour
tous les agriculteurs
pour encourager les candidats ont leur
permet de cumuler leur chômage partiel
et la rémunération d'un saisonnier qui
est plus ou moins équivalente au smic le
salaire minimum
la récolte assurée encore faut-il
trouver comment les coulées pour une
majorité d'agriculteurs la fermeture des
marchés publics c'est la disparition des
principaux points de vente une
catastrophe économique qui s'ajoutent à
des exportations plus difficile en temps
normal les chabot vendre 98 % d'heures
asperges ici à la ferme les règles de
distanciation sociale oblige impossible
de recevoir les clientes à sont
sécuritaires
la solution c'était de prendre mon
téléphone de me connecter à internet ray
et deux
eux de démarcher toutes les grandes
surfaces de la région
tous les jours je serai un sommet au
téléphone pour trouver des preneurs dans
les grandes surfaces de distribution
alimentaire un exercice laborieux mais
qui pour l'instant lui permet de sauver
sa saison
le prix reste
correct très correct justement vu un
manque de marchandise qui vient de
l'étranger
donc c'est un plus pour moi évidemment
les gens sont quand même à la recherche
aussi de ma de produits dont ils
connaissent l'origine des produits
qu'ils sont pas l'autre à transformer et
on lesquels ils en avaient confiance
donc
donc c'est bien que ça s'emballe là
dedans beaucoup de petites structures
c'est un message sans cesse renforcées
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
qui est venu lancer le président
maquereau en bretagne aujourd'hui la
france est préservée de la pénurie
grâce à la richesse de sa production
agricole en filière y la deuxième ligne
dans la guerre contre le corona virus
l'alimentation l'agriculture française
ont été au rendez vous ça je crois qu'il
faut à fuir cette deuxième ligne que
salue le président est affaiblie depuis
des années par des politiques
industrielles qui rallonge la chaîne de
distribution
mais dans la lutte contre le coronavirus
les consommateurs se réconcilier avec
les produits du terroir les
distributeurs aussi un geste patriotique
aujourd'hui qui s'inscrira dans la durée
espère-t-on ici ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada jablines en ile de france